long lines at fuel stations drivers
waiting patiently but without much hope
most gas stations in Mexico have run out
of fuel since the government shut down a
major pipeline and started delivering
gas by tanker trucks only the truth is
it's really bad because we already went
to several gas stations and we didn't
find gasoline it's been three days
already it's a disaster it's a disaster
everywhere I've been to two gas stations
already and they don't have any fuel
look at this where else can I go
yaki alone for years criminals have
tapped into pipelines stealing millions
of litres of fuel and depriving the
state-run oil monopoly Pemex of over
seven billion dollars in revenue that's
according to government estimates this
is not petty theft we're talking about
major robbery 1000 attacks on the
pipeline per day fifteen thousand litres
stolen each time how do they distribute
all that stolen gasoline well there was
an attitude of total complicity on the
part of Pemex they completely that plane
that I think they are the bearings
violent criminal gangs have long relied
on fuel seft
to supplement their income but says the
government accomplices within the
industry also seem to be a major part of
the problem
you